with dignity and respect committed to
free speech and common sense upbeat and
entertaining straight talking and direct
we may act eight each other and you
thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge a report out this
week recommended that schools should
swap teaching classical composer Mozart
for grime artist storm Z
to make music lessons more relevant to
kids we thought that swapping an old
out-of-touch man more popular pan is a
great idea look to better watch out
there's a new kid on the block everyone
like a Rachel shabby you can give us a
rendition of your best crime laser words
coming up on the program Carol wants to
ban the burqa Rachel calls for radical
action to tackle climate the climate
emergency Nick thinks we shouldn't
penalize private school kids and June
says our young people need inspiration
and free university education yeah but
first it's been an economic shock hit
the country this week as British steel
was placed into compulsory liquidation
thousands of jobs are in jeopardy after
talks with the government to save
Britain's second largest steel producer
broke down the official receiver has now
taken control of the company which
employs more than four thousand people
with a further 20 thousand in the supply
chain in a world that increasingly
features large economic bloc's
such as China India and the USA certain
British industries are bound to be
unable to compete fairly the decision on
whether or not to let them fall should
come down to how crucial they are for
our country for its infrastructure
construction industrial and military
uses still is one of those industries
that must be protected as a matter of
national importance whether British
steel collapse because of bad management
are falling pound or China dumping cheap
steel into European markets is secondary
to the fact that the government must now
step in to save it at least until a
buyer can be found and if nobody wants
to buy it the government should realise
it
[Music]
interesting one this let's first see
what the government is saying in the
shape of Greg Clark who's the business
secretary we've shown our willingness to
act having already provided the company
with 120 million pounds bridging
facility to enable it to meet its
emissions trading compliance cost the
government can only act within the law
which requires any financial support to
a steel company to be on a commercial
basis I have been advice as Greg Clark
that it would be unlawful to provide a
guarantee or loan on the terms of any
proposal that the company or any other
party has made so let's put that to one
side there are a couple of interesting
facts I want to challenge you
you said it must be protected so very
much I'm going to challenge you on that
and there's a fascinating aspect and
credit to Ed Conway the sky news from
Sky News who said in the first part that
the first two years China has
manufactured more steel than Britain has
since the height of the industrial
revolution in 1870
how far I am desperately sorry for the
People's Council and all the supporting
industries but I ask you this and indeed
other other pledges it got to the point
with coal where was actually more
expensive to get a tonne of coal out of
the ground and you did get are you
saying that you would go that far I have
nothing but sympathy I just fear that
this is another industry much like coal
mining and Dockers and printers that we
might have to face and unfortunately we
can see at Conway's point here
graphically this shows you oh the output
from the steel sector in the UK each
year over the course of the last years
going back to 1980 it's about 9 million
tonnes or so a year and you can see in
Germany there was a bigger output in the
u.s. it's about 9 times bigger but the
big story here is what's going on in
China just look at Chinese steel output
over the course of the last few decades
you can see it's an absolutely enormous
increase from relatively small amounts
in the 1980s up until in the 2000s it
has become by far and away the biggest
steel producer in the world well so he
saw that and it's unbelievable so now I
don't know about the quality of the
steel but it is cheap and they are
apparently dumping it onto European
markets so I still say yes and only
because steel you would you would pay
yeah Mort okay only because I think
still is different to call for one
specific reason and that's its relation
to national security
and military use and I think we need to
be able to build for example our own
tanks without having to rely on the
Chinese I mean just think Huawei
yeah and like I've just quickly add also
the difference with steel and coal is we
don't have an alternative with coal we
had multiple alternatives in terms of
nuclear power and so on and also just to
add to that I think will be in really
dangerous territory if we completely get
rid of our steel industry and our
manufacturing ability and then we're in
a place where we have to solely rely on
a China that brings all sorts of
problems
in terms of how they could then hike up
the price of it we are currently got the
biggest building project in the whole of
Europe with hs2 we've got cross rail in
London we've got that we've got that
Palace of Westminster surrounded in
scaffolding I would mandate you have to
buy British steel core what but a
British supply because a lot of that is
not being supplied by Britain yeah you
know it's a head and a heart thing you
know my heart was quite hard and hard so
my heart is desperately sad for the
5,000 women the 20,000 supply chain I
wasn't growing up in the north you stand
watch so many so many industries die and
I've seen what happens to the
communities as a result of that and you
know there's there's a big thing that
says to me if we can bail the banks out
why can't we bear other people it's all
about however that all that said my head
tells me we can't keep bailing out
failing industries you know it's you
know we've got to find new industries
that are competitive and and you know
and I know and I know that the young
people have Scunthorpe have been brought
up believing that industry is their only
option and I think my head tells me that
that 30 million that they want should be
spent on retraining relocating these
people to to go into a different
profession because it's not it's not
last month they paid 100 the government
paid a hundred million quid to pay that
the carbon bill for that you I mean it's
worth pointing out that Britain isn't
the only country that manufactures steel
and is up against you know cheap Chinese
essentially dumping aggressive still
dumping other countries also have
industries the reason that they survive
is a mixture of things one of the things
is that they have state management of
Industrial Policy which countries with a
manufacturing base should do we don't
the other thing and I'm gonna you know
you'll get you're gonna get a flavor of
where I'm coming from absolutely we
should be realizing an industry like
steel which we rely on for the reasons
that majid said you know security
defense automation railways of English
but also but also if we are looking at
an industry where you know we're looking
at 5,000 direct jobs and 20,000 indirect
jobs that is not just collapsing an
industry that is collapsing a community
and if the government isn't supposed to
intervene in those cases I don't know
what it's really so you saw that grab
you showed you sure you saw that guys
had said in the past 22 months how much
China is producing how much we've
produced so how is it sustainable who's
gonna pay for it that's what actually
why we have to is why we have to
interview Rachel where does it end if we
bailouts cancel and there's a very very
de do we bailout portal but for the car
workers do we both where does it stop
well let's take a sector-by-sector
analysis but certainly we have a
thriving British steel industry there's
nothing wrong with it those are good
jobs and those are still is something
that we will always need so there is a
case it is a thriving industry it
certainly is another time just look at
Germany something like Germany has state
direction of its manufacturing because
they understand that you can't leave it
to the market if I just want to take on
a promoter you said it's thriving it's
not thriving at the private equity for
the the firm that bought a grayble
capital had to the pledged to invest 400
million quid on it it's not war so this
is what I think this is what rachel is
referring to because actually a few
industries have increased their
productivity as much as steel in the
past couple of decades
for all its images are failing sector
the steel injury industry produces more
bang for the buck than most other parts
of UK industry and
and my point about the chart the reason
why we must protect our steel industry
that chart to me tells us where this
thing is headed and I think it's too
dangerous we cannot get to a place where
we allow China to completely dominate
the ceilings but the world in that place
we're in the places we allowed this
company to go down and we shouldn't let
it happen also just to refocus on the
huge personal cost I mean this is this
is collapsing a community and let's hear
from somebody from that community we
have steel worker Kalyn right so I can't
see where the other jobs are going to
come in this town and also with my
children and obviously I want them to
have a better life no really there's
nothing much here for us so it's mainly
the keeping these Works open at this
stage so we can't just all shake our
heads and say that's so sad we we can
actually prevent this from happening and
it's not just work how many families are
referred to it how many children are
affected this is gonna have widespread
consequences for an entire community and
an entire region and we can direct that
and direct you to someone who grew up in
a my community and I saw exactly what
happened there and it was it was tragic
but I think we've learned from that and
hopefully now we would be able to
retrain people like that young man
nobody just sees a different Carol we're
always going to need steel we don't want
to make don't want to make coal anymore
so there's a difference and also back to
your point this is you're saying how
long there is a way to sort it out so
that how long doesn't become an issue in
terms of making sure that we mandate the
British companies have to use British
steel Jim June I hope you're right I
really hope there's a way to say but it
breaks my heart to think of all those
people being out of work I really hope
there is a way